this is not a war over oil but make no
mistake russia's energy exports
represent considerable leverage the
reality is that mr putin has played the
world
democracies
and free markets like a fiddle and for
many in many respects
we've not only bought into it we created
this the situation that's because when
it comes to oil the global energy market
is already incredibly tight with demand
only just starting to keep pace with
supply and as one of the world's biggest
oil producers russia accounts for just
over 10 percent of oil globally so even
if we lose you know 10
of russia's production these prices
could you know easily go up to 140 150
it's why western countries have
hesitated to impose sanctions against
russian energy exports so how did it
come to this the market generally right
now is very short oil
ever since covid and even before there
has been
not enough investment happening to keep
up with demand
canada of course has oil alberta sits on
the third largest reserve in the world
but the industry is still without viable
means to get that product to world
markets keystone was cancelled and the
trans mountain pipeline expansion
doesn't come online until at least late
next year if we had a willing federal
partner
and
a realistic u.s energy security policy
we could completely displace
u.s russian oil imports global reliance
on oil already threatens the climate now
it's a factor in the western response to
war in ukraine and russia's escalating
security threat as well
heather urex west global news calgary